now if you remember the reality-based
community we acknowledge it might sound
a little crazy that andrew cuomo is
getting an
emmy so to banish any doubts from your
mind that he deserves it we've assembled
some of his most compelling performances
on the small screen this year
take it away fema says we're sending 400
ventilators
really what am i going to what am i
going to do with 400 ventilators
when i need 30 000 you pick the 26
000 people who are going to die it's
disrespectful
of people not to wear masks and should
there be sanctions yes
yes because it is a public health
emergency
and i think there should be a penalty
because you could literally kill someone
so what are you talking about how what
are you talking about
you're now going to override we did it
already
that's the law an orange zone in a red
zone
follow the facts but then you're
confused
every press conference sounds like he's
shaking down a pizza parlor in
bensonhurst for protection money
but he's not these are policies the last
one was andrew cuomo yelling at a
reporter for saying the schools in new
york city might close what
sedan cuomo then a couple of hours later
the schools actually did close
horrifying millions of parents if that's
not emmy award-winning dramatic irony
we don't know how to define it we still
don't know whether andrew cuomo's
brother at cnn will also receive an emmy
award
the brothers put on something of a joint
performance earlier this year as nursing
home deaths piled up
in the state of new york is it true that
this was the swab that the nurse was
actually using
on you and that at first it went into
your nose
and disappeared so that in scale
this was the actual swab that was being
used
to fit up that double barrel shotgun
that you have
mounted on the front of your pretty face
man they start doing prop comedy at cnn
watch out carrot top so if you're
confused about what the emmy committee
sees that you don't see
eddie scary is here to explain he's the
author of privileged victims how
america's culture fascists hijacked the
country
and elevated its worst people which it
did
he joins us tonight eddie great to see
you so the emmys
are decided like everything in this
country by committee
andrew cuomo's name comes up like what's
the conversation like how does he get
this
uh well i i thought about this um when
the new york times very first covered
his
um his like the initial like first three
press conferences he held which is what
they said was
um this is like a grandfatherly hug and
i'm not making this up they said this
was like
a a hug that we're receiving in a time
of grief
um well it's a hug and yet you're seeing
um
as we've seen in it has not changed
new york the state that the democratic
governor
um andrew cuomo has overseen
has been they have seen more deaths than
any other state
so uh take that as you will
i don't want to put the fault on him but
if we're going to say
which is what the rest of the media has
said cnn msnbc
new york times washington post which is
that well
we're looking at the upticks in the
trump country we're looking at the
uptick
the surge trump republican governors
well i'm sorry
did you overlook the idea that that um
we saw a lot of deaths in new york
connecticut
um massachusetts and i believe there's
one of the
democrats new jersey yes so we saw all
the deaths all there
there was nothing left for the virus to
do about rob a bank i think at this
point
so um if we're going to overlook all
that all that yes there was a lot of uh
there's been a surge in republican
places but let's talk about that a
little bit
i know i actually noticed that but i
want to back up just
four sentences here you said that the
emmy
committee is awarding this because they
believe that andrew cuomo's press
conferences on
kovid were quote like a hug but covid
precludes hugs hugging is something
we're not allowed to do if we're going
to prevent the transmission of kovitz so
i wonder
did they mean this ironically no i don't
think they meant it ironically
because we've seen um that this this
whole
virus has been the most fascinating and
um
i would say um
like it's fascinating but also like uh
complex and also like
really really really good thing that the
democrats and liberals have done
which is that um if if i get sick
it's my fault if you get sick it's my
fault
so they that's how they do it depending
on what your ideology is
um and and and yet yes i think that
that's how they're looking at it
they say oh democrat they're good they
they did the virus fine um republican or
right-leaning person no that's your
fault so this is how it goes and it
and it works out just the way they
wanted it it worked out just they wanted
it
and it was fascinating it was a really
good plan and
i think in some sense it worked all we
had to give up was reason and dignity
and return to the middle ages so yeah
it was a good deal hey scary great to
see you thanks thank you